Traducteur: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Comment pouvons-nous expliquer
que certaines personnes osent,
alors que d'autres n'osent pas ?
Comment peut-on expliquer
que par exemple Antoine Griezmann
à qui on a dit qu'il était trop petit
pour faire du football,
il a été rejeté par quatre clubs,
puisse obtenir la Coupe du Monde ?
Comment peut-on expliquer qu'une personne
comme Charles Aznavour,
ses professeurs de chant lui ont dit
qu'il n'avait ni la taille, ni la voix
et qu'il ferait mieux
de changer de carrière,
puisse devenir une légende de la chanson ?
Comment peut-on expliquer
que certaines personnes arrivent
à dépasser, à transcender la peur
qu'on peut avoir en parlant en public
ou la peur liée au regard des autres ?
Une des peurs les plus importantes
pour l'être humain,
c'est la peur d'être exclu
du cercle social.
La peur d'être rejeté.
Et par conséquent,
vous allez être effrayé à l'idée
du jugement ou du regard des autres.
Je me passionne pour cette question
depuis 15 ans
et ça m'a amené à faire trois découvertes
qui ont radicalement changé ma manière
d'observer, de voir
ce qu'était le regard des autres.
La raison pour laquelle
ça me passionne autant,
c'est que j'étais un jeune homme
mal dans sa peau,
avec des pensées de suicide,
j'avais du mal à oser
lever la main en cours,
à aborder cette fille qui me plaisait,
du mal à être moi-même
et j'arrivais même à faire une excellente
performance d'être capable le même soir
d'être précoce et d'avoir une panne.
Ce n'est pas donné à tout le monde,
sincèrement.
Du coup, je me suis lancé un défi,
celui de faire plein de choses
que je ne connaissais pas
et qui m'effrayaient
à cause du regard des autres.
Ça a commencé avec le fait
de lever la main en cours.
Mes potes me disaient :
« Tu penses que tu vas arriver à
être confiant en levant la main en cours ?
Tout le monde sait faire ça. »
À l'époque, j'étais trop stressé
pour pouvoir répondre que oui,
et c'était bien la seule idée que j'avais.
Alors, j'ai levé la main en cours,
abordé des centaines d'inconnus,
allé voir ces filles que me plaisait,
parlé en public,
je me suis même lancé le défi
d'aller dans des boîtes de nuit,
et parler à la première moitié
et leur dire bonjour.
Je me suis aperçu que
la deuxième moitié de la boîte de nuit,
celle qui arrive après,
elle se dit : « Mais qui c'est ce type
à qui tout le monde dit bonjour ? »
Ce qui se passe, vu que tout le monde
a peur du regard des autres,
et tout le monde a envie dans les yeux
de l'autre de paraître important,
la première moitié de la boîte, en passant
à côté de moi, me faisait : « Salut ! »
Des gens me demandaient :
« Est-ce que tu es le fils du patron,
une célébrité, qui tu es ? »
Ça m'a fasciné de me dire que
quelques détails dans ma communication
et ma manière de respirer
pouvait tout changer.
Je me suis dit que j'allais lancer
une chaîne Youtube.
Je restais stressé, pas très à l'aise
mais j'ai envie de partager
au plus grand nombre
comment faire pour arriver
à être plus à l'aise.
Donc, je démarre ma chaîne Youtube.
Je mets plusieurs jours à oser me filmer.
Je mets plusieurs jours à oser
mettre ma vidéo sur Youtube en privé.
Et je mets plusieurs jours
à oser cliquer sur le bouton publier
parce que je me demande
ce qu'on va penser de moi.
Notre cerveau est drôle
car il imagine que la Terre entière va
voir ma vidéo sur un milliard de vidéos.
J'ai trois abonnés :
moi, mon deuxième compte, ma mère.
(Rires)
Il y a un type qui sort de nulle part,
Youtube a dû embaucher
une bande de cousins,
pour entraîner les personnes
qui ont du mal avec le regard des autres.
il y a un type qui sort de nulle part
et qui marque :
« David, tu ne mérites pas de vivre. »
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
J'en rigole aujourd'hui ;
je n'en ai pas rigolé sur le coup.
J'ai continué de faire des vidéos,
plusieurs centaines.
Chaque vidéo essaye de faire
des choses différentes et nouvelles.
Dans le métro, dehors.
Essayer d'apprendre à devenir
un meilleur communiquant.
Un jour, un pote m'appelle.
C'est un fondateur d'un des plus gros
incubateurs de start-ups en Europe.
« David, je viens de diffuser une de
tes vidéos à toutes mes start-ups. »
Sur le coup, je suis trop content.
Je le remercie :
« C'est top la confiance que tu as en moi.
Quelle vidéo tu as choisie ? »
Il me dit : « Une de tes premières. »
Je dis : « Mais pourquoi t'as fait ça ?
Pourquoi une de mes premières ? »
« Je sais ce que je fais.
Je vais attendre quelques semaines
et leur donner une de tes dernières. »
« Pourquoi tu fais ça ? »
Il me dit : « Je veux leur montrer que
vraiment, tout est possible. »
(Rires)
Et sur le coup, comme vous, je me dis :
« C'est une critique ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire par là ? »
Ça m'a amené à faire trois découvertes
qui ont transformé ma vision.
Je vous montre une image
de mes premières vidéos.
J'avais testé les T-shirts
et je m'étais dit que ça ne marchait pas
à cause du T-shirt.
Je mets un costume et un type me dit
d'arrêter de mettre
le costume de mon père.
Ça n'était pas le costume de mon père.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi il a dit ça.
Mais grâce à lui, j'ai changé de costume.
(Rires)
Et je me suis aperçu que je mettais
énormément de valeur sur les critiques.
Il y avait toujours des gens
qui disaient : « Tu es trop jeune,
tu ne vas pas y arriver,
tu ne t'exprimes pas assez bien. »
Je mettais trop d'énergie là-dessus,
trop de poids à ce que
les autres pensaient de moi.
Donc j'ai continué et je me suis demandé
quel défi me ferait vraiment flipper.
Ancien timide, le plus stressant pour moi,
c'était de louer une salle.
Donc j'ai loué une salle
de 1 400 personnes.
Et je me suis dit que j'avais un mois
pour faire un one man show.
Sachant que j'ai demandé autour de moi
et qu'on m'a dit qu'en un mois
c'est impossible de faire un one man show.
Voici la salle, ça a donné ça.
1 400 personnes.
J'étais terrorisé.
Sincèrement, avant de monter sur scène,
je ne suis jamais allé autant de fois
aux toilettes en 20 minutes
avant de monter sur scène.
Ça m'a permis d'avoir
ma première découverte :
l'entraînement,
le fait de t'entraîner tous les jours
à faire des choses non connues,
le fait de te dépasser,
le fait de te remettre en question
et pourquoi pas apprendre des critiques
car il y a des critiques intéressantes,
je me suis rendu compte que
l'entraînement,
ça rend obsolète les critiques.
Plein de gens ont dit un tas de choses
sur le fait que je n'y arriverais pas.
Mais quand tu n'es pas concentré sur eux
mais que tu es concentré sur apprendre
et faire des choses que tu ne connais pas,
le temps qu'ils aient fini de parler,
toi, tu as progressé.
J'aimerais partager cette idée
et cette invitation,
à aller faire des choses
qui représentent un défi pour soi.
Chacun sa taille.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai le privilège, la chance,
de côtoyer, rencontrer, interviewer,
accompagner des personnes
qui excellent dans leur domaine,
producteur de films, des sportifs
olympiques, des champions du monde,
des entrepreneurs qui génèrent
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros,
peu importe là où ils en sont,
tous, il y a quelque chose qui nous fait
peur lié au regard des autres.
Mon invitation est de dire :
« Qu'est-ce que je peux faire
qui me fait vraiment flipper
et qui peut-être va me permettre
en plus d'être fier de moi ? »
Être là avec vous me permet de repenser à
ce jeune homme que j'étais et de me dire :
« Waouh ! »
Ça me paraissait impossible
et ça allait au-delà de ce que j'imaginais
car ça a démarré avec un truc
où mes potes se moquaient de moi :
lever la main en cours.
Je suis allé plus loin dans ces défis
et je me suis dit :
« OK, qu'est-ce qui me ferait
encore plus flipper que le spectacle ? »
Je vais partir aux États-Unis
et je vais annoncer à tout le monde
sur ma chaîne Youtube et partout
que je vais interviewer trente Américains
considérés comme inaccessibles.
Sachant que quand j'annonce ça,
j'ai aucune idée comment faire.
Je me retrouve donc à New York.
Première fois à New York.
Je ne sais pas comment je vais faire
et j'obtiens l'interview avec Seth Godin,
une légende du marketing aux États-Unis,
c'est quelqu'un qui a accompagné Yahoo.
À la fin de l'interview, il me dit :
« Quand est-ce qu'il est ton train ? »
Sous-entendu,
ce serait bien que tu dégages.
(Rires)
Je suis sur le quai du train,
c'est ma première interview
de ma vie à New York, aux États-Unis,
et je suis en train de réaliser
que je viens de rater une des interviews
les plus importantes de ma vie.
La raison pour laquelle
j'ai raté cette interview,
c'est qu'en fait mon anglais est pourri.
(Rires)
Et donc, Seth Godin,
il passe aux TED aux États-Unis,
le plus gros TED, à la télé, à la radio,
et il est habitué à raconter des blagues.
Quand il raconte une blague,
il a l'habitude que les gens rigolent.
Mais vu mon mauvais anglais,
quand il raconte une blague,
je ne comprends pas que c'est une blague
ou je comprends deux minutes plus tard.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
mes interviews suivantes,
quand tu les regardes
sur ma chaîne Youtube américaine,
tu vois que je rigole dans le doute.
(Rires)
Il y a des moments où je rigole
et ça n'a rien à voir,
et c'est pour ça que j'ai des commentaires
sur ma chaîne américaine comme ceci,
c'est la traduction :
Super interview du côté de l'interviewé,
donc pas moi,
mais si j'entends encore ce Frenchie Boy,
c'est une traduction,
pouffer de rire comme une fillette,
trois petits points.
Des comme ça, j'en ai des centaines.
Des gens me disent que c'est mieux
d'arrêter de parler anglais
car ça leur fait mal aux oreilles.
(Rires)
Des gens me disent que c'était déshonorer
les gens que j'interviewais
avec mon anglais de merde.
Alors je me suis lancé d'autres défis :
parler par exemple devant 200 personnes
qui étaient les dirigeants de boîtes
de S&P500, c'est comme le CAP40.
À la fin de mon intervention,
j'ai quelqu'un qui va voir l'animateur
et qui lui dit : « Pourquoi lui ? »
(Rires)
Sincèrement quoi, pourquoi lui,
il y en d'autres excellents.
Et un autre dit à l'animateur :
« Tu sais, dans tous les intervenants,
il n'y en a qu'un seul que je retiendrai.
Je n'ai pas tout compris
ce qu'il a raconté.
Mais par contre, je pense que
notre entreprise
a un peu plus besoin
de l'état d'esprit qu'il a eu.
Faire 10 000 km, aller parler
une langue qu'il ne connaît pas
devant des personnes qui l'impressionnent,
je pense que si on faisait un peu plus ça
dans notre entreprise,
des trucs qui pourraient se passer. »
Alors j'ai commencé
à me poser des questions :
suis-je le seul qu'on critique ?
Alors je suis allé sur un site
Internet appelé Allociné,
voir ce que les gens pensaient
de mon film préféré,
Cinq oscars, deuxième meilleur film
au box-office monde l'année de sa sortie.
Quand tu regardes les commentaires
les plus mauvais sur Allociné,
il y a des gens qui sont sincères.
Je vous en ai sélectionné trois
que j'ai vus aujourd'hui.
Je les ai trouvés magnifiques.
Le premier :
« C'est sans aucun doute un des films
les plus ratés de l'histoire du cinéma,
(Rires)
Bref, une daube magistrale. »
C'est mon film préféré.
(Rires)
« Le film est tellement nul
qu'il devient une parodie,
les acteurs jouent mal
et n'ont aucun charisme. »
Et le dernier, je l'ai trouvé efficace :
« Insupportable. »
Ça m'a soulagé !
Ça m'a soulagé car je me suis dit
si Gladiator, les gens peuvent dire ça,
franchement, tout est possible
pour moi maintenant.
Ça m'a soulagé et donné
ma deuxième découverte :
c'est qu'en fait, quoi que tu fasses,
tu peux être le meilleur sportif au monde,
tu peux être Michael Jordan
ou Kobe Bryant, n'importe qui,
exceller, passer toute ta vie
à exceller dans un domaine,
l'art, la science, l'entrepreneuriat,
tu auras toujours des gens pour dire
que ce que tu fais, c'est pourri.
Et le pire, c'est qu'ils sont sincères.
(Rires)
Ça a été une deuxième découverte
importante pour moi
qui est appuyée
par des travaux scientifiques.
Geraint Rees, professeur
à l'université de Londres,
s'est rendu compte que chaque être
humain a un cerveau qui est différent.
Par conséquent,
notre perception du monde
est différente pour chaque personne.
C'est la raison pour laquelle,
ce qui est important pour toi,
pour d'autres, c'est pourri.
C'est une bonne nouvelle en fait.
On peut se libérer de l'idée que
d'autres personnes puissent nous critiquer
et juste intégrer cette deuxième
découverte : la critique est inévitable.
Je le savais déjà, j'ai rencontré
des scientifiques pour me le partager
et vivre cette expérience m'a libéré.
Donc, vu que c'est inévitable,
autant aller faire ce qui me fait vibrer.
Si c'est l'art qui me fait vibrer,
autant aller faire de l'art.
Si c'est voyager, voyagez,
si c'est apprendre une langue,
apprenez-la.
Faire un tour du monde,
partir dans l'espace,
créer votre entreprise.
Combien de personnes
n'osent pas faire des choses
qui sont importantes pour elles
juste parce quelqu'un de leur entourage,
un ami, un enfant, un parent,
un collègue de travail,
qui leur ont dit : « C'est mort. »
Suite à ça,
je suis allé plus loin dans un autre défi
d'interviewer des personnes qui excellent.
J'ai pu interviewer un des plus grands
acteurs français, comédien,
qui fait aussi du théâtre.
Et en privé, il m'a raconté
une anecdote de sa vie.
Il est sur scène,
devant une salle comme ça -
sincèrement, c'est impressionnant
d'entrer dans une salle comme ça -
il est 19 heures 30,
le spectacle démarre à 20 heures.
Il est paniqué, il ne se sent pas bien,
il est habitué au stress
mais là, c'est particulier.
19 heures 45.
Toujours dans les loges, il est stressé,
sans arriver à se rappeler de son texte.
20 heures, l'heure du début du spectacle,
il est toujours dans les loges.
À votre avis, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
20 heures 15.
Toujours dans les loges, paniqué,
les mains moites, il n'est pas bien.
Plus le temps passe, plus il se dit :
« Avec la renommée que j'ai,
c'est vraiment la honte
de monter sur scène si je bafouille,
si je ne connais pas mon texte. »
20 heures 30.
Toujours dans les loges.
Ça fait trente minutes que
la salle attend.
Son metteur en scène est perdu
autant que lui et lui dit :
« Fais quelque chose, monte sur scène,
prends ton texte, vas-y ! »
« Je ne vais pas monter
avec mon texte, c'est ridicule. »
20 heures 45.
Il décide de prendre son texte
et de monter sur scène.
À votre avis, que se passe-t-il
suite à ça ?
Il va passer tout le reste de la pièce
de théâtre avec le texte à la main.
Incapable de retrouver son texte.
C'est long,
une pièce de théâtre entière
quand tu es stressé, paniqué
et que tu as ton texte à la main.
Et à la fin, il va avoir
la « standing ovation »
la plus longue, la plus grande
qu'il ait jamais eue de toute sa carrière.
Trois ans plus tard,
il est dans une autre ville et quelqu'un
vient lui dire : « J'étais là ! »
« T'étais où ? »
(Rires)
« J'étais là ! »
« T'étais où ? »
« J'étais là ce soir-là.
Le soir où vous aviez votre texte.
Ce n'est peut-être pas pour vous
le meilleur spectacle de votre vie,
mais pour moi,
ça a été le plus impactant dans ma vie.
Ce soir-là a transformé ma vie.
Vous n'imaginez pas le nombre
de choses que je n'osais pas faire
par peur d'être critiqué, en pensant que
ce n'était pas encore parfait,
car j'attendais d'être parfait
pour démarrer mon entreprise,
pour parler en public.
Ce soir-là, vous m'avez libéré,
je me suis donné l'autorisation
d'aller réaliser mes rêves.
Merci.
Merci. »
Son histoire m'impacte énormément,
car je m'aperçois que je suis
extrêmement attaché au regard des autres.
En fait, on est extrêmement addict
à être valorisé par les autres.
Je me rends compte
qu'à partir du moment où tu te libères
du besoin d'être valorisé par les autres,
tu te libères aussi au passage,
d'être critiqué par les autres.
Plus important encore que ça,
j'ai fait une troisième découverte,
hyper importante pour moi.
En réalité, le seul risque que tu as
en prenant le risque d'être critiqué,
c'est d'inspirer quelqu'un.
Si quelqu'un te voit, t'entend, te regarde
et se dit s'il ou elle peut le faire,
je peux le faire aussi.
Combien ça vaut d'inspirer sa mère,
son père, ses enfants, un inconnu ?
Cela ne vaut-il pas une petite critique ?
Quelqu'un qui va juste te dire
que ce que tu fais, c'est nul.
Je vous ai parlé de beaucoup de choses
de plus en plus grandes pour moi.
Mais il y avait un truc que
je n'osais pas faire,
qui est pour beaucoup de gens
extrêmement simple,
que j'ai laissé chaque année passer
en me disant que je le ferais plus tard.
Ça me terrorisait bien plus
que d'aller passer sur scène en anglais.
C'était dire : « Je t'aime » à mon père.
Mon père a été abandonné par son père,
puis par sa mère, puis par sa grand-mère.
Il a eu du mal à comprendre
ce que c'était de se sentir aimé.
Du coup, j'ai eu une adolescence
où je lui en ai beaucoup voulu
et je prétextais
mon manque d'estime sur lui.
Dire je t'aime à mon père
était hyper stressant pour moi,
bien plus que tout ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui dans ma vie.
Encore une fois, c'est cette peur
du regard des autres.
La peur que mon père ne réponde pas.
La peur qu'il me rejette car je me suis
senti rejeté par lui pendant mon enfance.
Et un jour, je prends mon téléphone
et j'écris à mon père :
« Papa, je t'aime. »
Faire ça,
cet acte de courage pour moi
était plus important
que plein de choses que j'ai pu accomplir.
Le lendemain, pas de réponse de mon père.
Le surlendemain,
pas de réponse de mon père.
Le troisième jour, j'oublie le SMS.
Le fait d'oublier le SMS fut
une des plus belles victoires de ma vie.
Car pour la première fois de ma vie,
ce n'était plus si important
que mon père ou quelqu'un me reconnaisse.
Ce n'était plus si important
qu'il me réponde.
Car j'avais fait
ce qui était important pour moi.
Deux semaines s'écoulent.
Mon père a dû pendant ce temps
se demander ce qu'on répondait
à un tel SMS.
Car personne ne lui a dit ça.
Après deux semaines,
il a trouvé une formule
que j'ai trouvée intéressante :
« La réciproque est vraie. »
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
J'aurais reçu ce SMS à 15 ans,
je lui en aurais voulu pour ça.
Mais quand j'ai reçu ce SMS,
j'ai les larmes aux yeux.
car en fait mon père, je réalise,
par toutes ces expériences,
le prendre dans mes bras
alors qu'il se raidit,
que mon père en fait m'a toujours aimé
sauf que j'étais incapable de le voir
car on a deux cerveaux
et enfances différents.
Mon père m'a donné
tout ce que lui n'a pas eu :
un toit, à manger, des études.
Quand je pensais qu'il ne m'aimait pas,
il me disait en fait : « Fais attention,
continue tes études car moi je sais
ce que c'est de ne pas manger. »
J'ai compris que
mon père m'avait toujours aimé.
Ça a changé notre relation
et j'ai beaucoup de gratitude
pour lui aujourd'hui.
Car il participe à la réussite
de mon entreprise.
Car j'ai osé traverser
ce regard de l'autre
et être prêt à être rejeté par lui.
J'aimerais terminer par une invitation.
L'invitation que vous alliez faire
au moins une petite chose
inconfortable pour vous.
Elle peut être petite aux yeux des autres
ou grande pour vous.
Ça peut être un truc énorme
aux yeux des autres
ou simplement lever la main en cours.
J'imagine un monde
et j'ose imaginer avec vous un monde,
où si nous, ensemble, on ose faire
des choses qui nous inspirent,
on pourra peut-être voir ensemble
un monde où des jeunes, des enfants
et des adultes osent vivre la vie
qui les fait vibrer,
peu importe ce que les autres pensent.
J'ai envie de terminer avec cette phrase
de Steve Jobs que j'adore,
qui a marqué ma vie :
« Votre temps est limité,
ne le gâchez pas en menant
une existence qui n'est pas la vôtre. »
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements